[Music]
just stop you're crying It's The Sign of
the time
and welcome to the final show stop your
crying baby
that's one way to impress the coaches on
The Voice perform a song by someone
they're friends with I'm so stoked about
your song collection
look I know he's got a connection with
the original singer okay okay
I know him that him is of course Niall
Horan's former One Direction bandmate
Harry Styles who made his solo debut
with sign of the times back in 2017.
[Music]
Laura Littleton brought the house down
putting a country-flavored spin on it
for her blind audition
[Music]
[Applause]
after capturing both Nile and Kelly's
attention Laura chose to be on team Nile
so it seems like Kelly should have
blocked him instead of Blake Shelton I
wish I could have had you on my team
[Laughter]
what you've created here I'm so honored
that I get to be here for your step away
getting to be a part of this process
from the very start to the very end
right now the emotions are running high
in season 23. Blake's farewell season
have a great night all right I'll see
you tomorrow all right okay all right
oh I know about the sign and it's fine
because it's true Mr Shelton it is your
last season here on the voice now how
much are you milking the retirement card
this season you have no idea
he's not even answering you won't forget
that's for sure
I've mentioned it uh
uh a couple of times of course we have
two Fresh Faces joining The Voice family
now you come from a music competition
show I've been through it I know exactly
what it's like to be especially for the
younger ones like it was on that show
when I was like 16. what's your name why
are you here today I'm here to be the
best therapist I can be in the world I
just want to be like just kind of
nurture them a little bit and kind of
make sure to enjoy it I think that's the
biggest thing for me if Blake wins this
season it will be his 10th Kelly has won
four in the past chance I wanted to ask
you how have they initiated you in how
have they welcomed you in uh it's been
awesome Kelly's very very sweet very
nice to me
um Blake is here and
[Music]